so uh we are here for you guys today
that's why we came out to do the panel
so we're going to go right to questions
from you we got we got an area right
over here it's very well lit hello
everyone good afternoon my question is
or then I echo DITA my question is how
would you compare your training to
express emotion on your role on this
show to your roles in past dramas like
the visitor and mother of George uh hi
nice to meet you yeah I think the thing
that I loved and watching this was so
beautiful to see that hundred year I
mean the hundred years feels like a
hundred no no it doesn't and that's as
beautiful as that I just I'm so grateful
to be a part of this and of this family
and seeing all the work that's been done
and really I was thinking about stepping
into this amazing piece of work in
season three and it was really about
learning from those who had created who
had built it up the astounding mr.
Andrew Lincoln down there who has held
this ship for a hundred episodes and
then of course Lennie James in that
first episode as well which totally I
was gripped by how they created that
very stunning dynamic of this world and
so really I followed the lead of
watching two seasons worth of how these
people had built this very powerful
human story and that's what guided me it
to to tell the story that I was called
to tell thanks for the question
[Applause]
what's up my family hello
well fellow um I gotta say mr. Andrew
Lincoln you're my hero
every Sunday night we're all watching
you guys
my question was originally for you
Christian Lincoln but I think it's
better for the whole cast do you guys
ever crave a comedic moment or a comedic
scene though there's so much drama in
the show I do think I am pushing for a
musical episode for years I think I
think that's a good idea
I'm not gonna lie sometimes we spoof
sometimes sometimes we just get into
spoof mood and you know when the cameras
aren't rolling and we exclude some stuff
we spoof ourselves and that introduction
of Jesus as a character was as I think
one of the the most the one of the
lighter mamasita they gave me Jerry so I
get plenty accounting you they gave me a
tiger and they gave me a Jerry I get all
I have all the fun I have all the fun he
takes the guy go home go ahead Michelle
opana
um actually I do have a question for
Jeffrey by M carries will there ever be
like I'm just so where there's just like
I don't know karaoke nice or something
they're just chillin Alexandria but also
for Jeffrey on where do you think if
Sasha had lived where do you think she
would've end go and Lincoln's
organization first of all every night is
karaoke night for negan
he's having fun I you know that would
have been an interesting storyline
moving forward I I think Megan saw
something in Sasha but I think he sees
something in every one of these
characters that is rare in this world
they're all very strong and as a team
and individually and I think he respects
everyone he's come up against and Sasha
was no different and he liked her she
knew that she had a good head on her
shoulders and she was a would have been
a great Ally so I think you know he was
as sad as everyone else to see her go hi
big fan and I was just wondering how you
guys think that Megan will influence the
development of Carl's character and if
it will affect his relationship with
Rick I hope so yeah I mean ever you know
ever since the the comics of you know
the whole Carl and negan storyline came
out I've been so so excited for for the
whole arc between the two so yeah I mean
I can't I can't wait to see something I
can do yeah I I have one quick question
for the people who were there what was
the first scene shot on the show the
first scenes shot on the show the first
scene shot of a show I know mine it was
a car flip right with the cup no it
wasn't the cup it was throwing down the
yet his man Jon Bernthal on that road
doing the car block and a John had and
his knee was busted and so I had to
drive him around Atlanta on the way to
work and I kept driving on the left hand
side of the road
and then I had to get in a car with him
and we had to drive at about 80 miles an
hour and then stop abruptly and John has
never sweated more in his life and she
said this is the terrible ID here you
know and and then we shot that whole day
and I think that the rushes went back to
to New York and we just looked like we
were in a monsoon because it was Atlanta
in the midsummer and we were dressed as
you know cops and they came on setting
they said is there no makeup on this
show and then they came in suits in in
mid-summer
and they went forget the makeup on this
[ __ ] you know but it was it was Jon
Bernthal and me terrified and trying to
sort of make sense of where we were it
was thrilling and and it's very moving
to sort of hear just a hundred episodes
this has been the most incredible saying
in my life it's been the most incredible
experience right hi to everyone
especially to Rick from my mom Lisa
uh-huh she's over there she's over there
yeah hi hi Lisa so my question is for
Lauren as Maggie what do you think Glen
would want the baby to know most what I
wanted the baby to know most importantly
growing up in this apocalyptic world
you're gonna make everybody cry how
great was that just watching the I mean
the trailer but uh really amazing but
watching those 100 if this just recap
just now I feel like
I don't know how jubilant and heroic
Glens and Steven is in all this and I
think that what he would have wanted to
teach the baby or expose the baby to is
just that bravery and comedy and just
impulsive energy that he had I think
it's probably hard to say but I hope
that everybody of the families that is
alive is going to pause those things on
and tell those stories too to this new
little girl or guy as well as who
Herschel was and who best was and who
Michael who played Abraham was um yeah
yeah it looks great
Pepi answer your question is Jeffrey
nobody either but you like mom where she
like Rose about the character did I walk
did I leave a [ __ ] carrot there what do
I like most about Meighan I find him
very amusing I think he's got a great
sense of humor and then in these dark
days expensing humor will help you get
through what do I like least about him
that he wears a leather jacket on 120
degrees
we were going to go t-shirt but we
thought the leather jacket looked cooler
I'm really sorry it is cooler so uh
Alanna Masterson yes you what has been
your favorite season to shoot when I
first read the script I was coming in
with the governor and I was like oh no
one's gonna like me and then and then I
got to meet Stephen who just kind of the
best character to come in with because
he bridged the gap for the for the
originals and for the people that were
new and we had the most fun that season
we all hung out and played pranks on
each other and just did really scary
stuff we did karaoke that would be my
favorite season working with Stephen was
you know the best she's the best so yeah
I was thinking about actually like
concerning this family like the
friendships that have come to pass
from this time on the show like I mean I
was wondering actually how many of us
knew each other before we started
shooting I don't think many did maybe
Lenny
could you I'm myself an Andy we kind of
knew each other we had friends in common
but we then we'd never works with each
other in fact is one of our you just
reminded me of when we first shot the
pilot and there was a moment where both
of us went in the corner these two
Englishmen playing these Americans and
when can you believe it exactly yeah it
was the only times we have known in my
accent in eight years when I went yeah
unbelievable I've always wanted to work
with you
well Melissa and I work together on the
mist that's where I met her originally
and and Frank loved her character and
her performance so much that the button
at the end of the mist was was and do a
lot to how Melissa portrayed her
character when the [ __ ] hit the fan so
to speak and Norman and I work together
on John Carpenter Masters of Horror
called cigarette burns so we had work
together just right before the show and
and Chandler and I work together on a
Lifetime TV movie called the wrong man
and he played Julia Arman son I need a
copy copy of this movie oh I guess I
work with Chad actually um me and Chad
well I played his estranged wife on
Broadway
I forgot that yeah I knew Chad incest he
worked with Chad and mr. Gilardi Oh God
yes yes we work together on the wire
done Baltimore oh the wire how to wire
connection and we got where Batman's
parents they all tell Batman were on
another show no first I wanted to thank
you all for coming in light of the
circumstances I'm sure everybody here
appreciates that and my question is for
Andrew how difficult has it been to
perfect your accent and especially the
way you say Carl and um
perfect is a big word though yeah I
would say it's a work in progress but
it's working progress oh no I yeah the
cut I don't know what's the thing with
the call yeah I I have to why I have to
say coming from Kentucky and my father's
name is Carl that's how a lot of people
say it so you're thank you that's it's
authentic to the region that I'm from I
don't watch it did I why does he say how
does he say it guys
hora hora is it more like coral is that
Laurel is that what you're talking about
Briggs Briggs do I do I told like that
yeah 409 409 that's all you did yeah
that's all you said well another maybe
I'll get it right he wasn't well in 409
you've been beaten up a lot I'm trying
to spend you linear Andy yeah you know
is now Google you know garbled back what
happened has anybody here play the
drinking game with Carl where every time
Andy says Carl you have to take a shot
wait did you make it to the end okay
they surprised if you know here we go
guys is anybody have you been able to
get any drinks in the whole core core
core core core core ha ha
[Applause]
[Laughter]
someone's good on the floor it is then
my name is Lauren and I just want to say
that me and my whole family really love
your show and appreciate you all and
this is me and my siblings are here and
this is our first comic-con we came all
the way from Sweden my question is will
we see the walking dead in any other
part of the world Scott I would say it
is entirely possible that that could
happen I'm going to continue to give you
a long ambiguous answer on that but I
would say it's it's something that I
would say it's something we look like
the walking dead Sweden coming in 29
[Laughter]
it's something we want to see and it's
cool there in the summer right yeah
we're looking for Walking Dead the
Serengeti Walking Dead Death Valley
walking again inside a volcano and
everyone wears leather jackets her
jackets for everybody Thank You Lauren
next up the kind of show my name is Eve
my question is either for the producers
or Jeffrey Dean Morgan I'm a big fan of
the comics as well and his word usage in
the comics is even more liberal than it
is on the show so I'm wondering if
there's ever a line that you really
wanted to include in the show but the
FCC put a kibosh on every line he says
every single one I mean we are allowed
seven shits like one goddamn zero Fox
and as you know mr. Kirkman wrote a
character that happens to enjoy that
particular word so I think he says it
literally more than every single other
word so everything you can use it for
every other word - it's amazing but
that's why we have blue rat so we can
say all those go blu-ray Rosita my sorry
my question is mainly for the original
cast do you remember where you were what
you were doing when you realize this
show was going to be a big success I was
about 50 yards away for a month where
I'm sat now and I was leaning against
the wall and it was the first time we
came to comic-con and we showed the
trailer and I was feeling sick and I'm
within sort of a minute and a half I
heard this incredible sounds I didn't
know what it was it was and and it was
it was you guys and and it was the most
amazing sense of relief that we weren't
messing up your show so so that was my
first time when I realized that this was
we had to give it to you guys you know
this wasn't our thing anymore it was a
much bigger thing how many of you were
here eight years ago so that wow thanks
Wow thank you awesome how many of you
will be here eight years from now for
that time and this is the question how
many of us will be hearing very few very
few zero
yeah Chandler hope so I mean where do
you remember where he was answering the
much more important yes yeah um
man you know you know for me the show
was just like a super gradual thing I
don't because since the show started
I've been going and doing conventions
and meeting you guys and you know as I
got bigger I could just feel it getting
bigger and but I do remember when I got
the part I was like you know I was 10
and I had probably you know both of my
parents were teachers and so it was kind
of hard from this class when we pay me
to audition so it was probably like my
last audition like doing something so if
I didn't get this I probably wouldn't be
acting but I remember just like running
around my house just like screaming and
yelling and being so excited to be a
part of this and yeah yeah and so ever
since then I've you know been really
lucky to be a part of the show and very
happy to be here
[Applause]
go ahead hi there I'm Neal from San
Diego so it's a bit of a flight to get
here I was wondering are there going to
be any more new characters interesting
characters introduced the season new
interesting characters the answer is yes
but we shouldn't tell you about them now
but deal if you have a follow up up
we'll take it okay get out lady get out
of the way he's getting to follow up on
side don't jump the gun you'll get your
question my follow up is do any of you
have any interest any opinions on our
new president Trump okay lady lady if
you can real that was a bad we made a
mistake we're very sorry just take it
back Neal just get out of here for
trying let's not bring the room down now
ma'am I wish you had fought when I had
said can you get out of the way he could
have said no he could have saved us all
all kinds of trouble go to 2018 go ahead
hi my name is Houston I'm here from
South Carolina so we're neighbors I feel
your heat in humidity pain I can relate
anyway my question is for Norman Reedus
[Music]
Norman you did so my question is has
Darryl started working on a nickname for
Glenn and Maggie baby because little
ass-kicker is a tough act to follow
Wow I guess it is isn't it um she's a
good name for the baby
um she's put me on the spot I don't know
I I'm sitting here and I'm listening to
these questions and every
and getting wrapped up in autism and
looking at that that retrospective and
over here just almost tearing up like I
got to say like this has been such a
good experience for all of us and we've
always had each other's back and we have
your back and you guys have our backs
and it's it's been fantastic I have to
say it still is fantastic what a
nickname damn I don't know maybe right
back say what I said baby got your back
baby got your back
I like that too that cannon uh I still
don't even understand what the whole
cannon thing is and all of this stuff I
just learned it fast not long ago hey
John you're going to shoot that idea out
of a cannon right is it what it just
means you're going to shoot that idea
out of a cannon right probably I guess
um I don't know I don't even know where
I'm at well I hi everyone I just woke up
and I don't know what's going on good
morning girl seems very excited to ask a
question so let's delay that as long as
possible
Rohan you're adorable i me and my dad
want to know like is anybody life will
be affected and like we want to know
with go ever be some character who's
immune to the zombie bite or if you guys
lover to like explore looking for a cure
sweet what about is we Walking Dead
Sweden
where we get questions like these we
like to not be as definitive as possible
because we don't want to reveal anything
but the answers are no and no I won
because it's been done in a lot of other
zombie stories and - because it's you
know it's kind of a mythology breaking
proposition you know you don't want that
kind of thing as far as somebody being
immune but uh and we have dabbled with
that a little bit in the other show but
as far as like actually trying to solve
the thing I mean I've always thought
that one of the best things about this
show is that it's not about scientists
and it's not about people that would
take that on as a task because I feel
like that's unrelatable I think if there
were a zombie apocalypse I don't know
that there's always like five people in
this room that might be you know that
would like have that job but there would
be five people yeah and we blew them up
the first season yeah yeah but you know
with like this show is about the you
know people in their struggles to
survive and I think that's what the
focus is and so to you know go off and
try and solve this I think would be a
boring show so definitely not a good
question go ahead
hi my name is Andre I just have to say
I'm a huge fan I love The Walking Dead
but for this one my question is for Carl
how is Carl and Chandler any different
from the show well I mean I'm not a
murderer but we go I like that it's
getting that on the record yeah yeah um
I don't know I mean I mean Carl he's um
I don't know he's a very ballsy dude
like like showing up like with like
showing up negan like damn I couldn't do
that
I don't know I think you could no no no
[Laughter]
but I mean I definitely had a lot of fun
doing it that's for sure I don't know I
don't I mean coral their hair is
different yeah yeah yeah I mean our hair
styles are just ya know that the long
hair just wouldn't work you already wear
a hat yeah yeah yeah is that what that
did I go get my because he just got you
eyes yeah that's how we kind of aha he
just said coral you did I think we can
squeeze in a couple more questions I'm
sorry guys but this will be the last
question
oh really oh so to quote one of my
favorite movies The Killing Joke it only
takes one bad day to ruin your whole
life so this questions will all of the
cast members and writers what would it
take for your interval individual
character or a character that you have
written to turn into someone like negan
besides the death of Gwyn of course
first of all what the hell is turning
out like negan what's the issue with
that
you act like that's a bad thing you have
a microphone there well the way I said
we all can't wear leather jackets as to
let you though okay that is a heavy
question you're right you know one of
the things I love about the show is that
everybody is in a horrible circumstance
but not everybody chooses to be like
negan you know people most of these
people somehow fight for their humanity
in a bad situation I was really I hadn't
seen that the trailer before tonight I
was watching the first time with you
guys now getting really emotional about
it because the thing is every one of
these guys have been knocked down in
some way or another but they come back
and they fight and I think that's what
draws people to the show is that if they
fight to hold on to who they are as
people you know not everyone turns into
a psychopath people find their way to I
to be a little bit better I love you
Jesse
that's [ __ ] don't worry the
psychopath
you